>> A member of the Science and
Humanities Scholars Program,
today Sophie Rose Zucker is
earning a Bachelor's Degree
in Chemistry with university
honors and a Bachelor's Degree
in Creative Writing
with college honors.
Sophie has been an active of
the Carnegie Mellon community,
serving on the Executive Board
of Alpha Chi Omega sorority,
President of MORF,
CMU"s feminist club,
and Editor-in-Chief
of the Oakland Review,
CMU's literary magazine.
Following graduation, Sophie
will work for Epic Systems
of Madison, Wisconsin,
a software company
for healthcare organizations.
Sophie.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
>> Thank you for that wonderful
introduction, Dr. Suresh.
Thank you, everyone.
How do I look?
[ Laughs ]
All right.
Let's begin.
My heart is in the work.
Uh. Those words have followed us
throughout our college careers,
haven't they?
They were pressed into our
minds during orientation,
spoken with passion and rigor
by university officials,
upperclassmen, and staff
as they promised us
that we too would put
our hearts in the work.
We would be Andrew Carnegie.
When I was a high school
junior, those words inspired me.
My favorite subject
in school was Latin,
and I thought I would
never drink in college.
Oh, sorry it's raining, guys.
[laughs] I walked through
Carnegie Mellon's campus
and I saw myself here in a
world of people passionate
about their studies and
passionate about the future.
When I was a freshman, "my heart
is in the work" challenged me.
I think it challenged
all of us, right?
[ Laughs ]
Challenged us to sign up for
the most student organizations
at the Activities Fair.
I don't know about you,
but I think I'm still
on the Tartans D-List.
Challenged us to take on classes
we knew we probably shouldn't be
taking as freshmen, despite
our advisor's recommendations,
and challenged us to step
out of our comfort zones.
Sometimes "my heart is in the
work" translated to "work hard,
play hard," and each of us
interpreted that in our own way.
Maybe it was going to
my first college party
and seeing a guy breathe
fire in front of me.
Maybe it was my friend who
called me at 6:30 in the morning
from a walk home
down Morewood just
to tell someone her secrets.
Or maybe it was my
roommate, who started research
with faculty her freshman
year and saw the path
to her future laid out in
front of her, bright and clear.
As we progressed through
college, though, "my heart is
in the work" took
on a nasty meaning.
It became a curse, a
pejorative, a joke.
It became something we muttered
at three AM while struggling
throughout problem sets
or during long weekends
in practice rooms
and acting studios.
Were our hearts really
in the work
as we planned another event
we knew nobody would attend?
And were our hearts in the
work at midnight on Sundays
in Hunt Library trying
to finish lab reports,
gorging on snack
food and Red Bull?
In the middle of
my sophomore year,
I sat in my advisor's office,
asking him for guidance
about what to do that summer.
I didn't know where to go.
I felt like I should start
doing research because everyone
in the chemistry
department does research,
and sophomore summer was
too late to start research
and I wanted to take
more writing classes
and I wouldn't have time for
research during the year.
I just couldn't do it all.
I grew frantic, panicked,
and I was about to cry
when he just calmly looked
at me and he said, "Sophie,
over the past year,
it has seemed
that chemistry has
excited you less and less
and other things have
excited you more."
And just like that, a whole
world opened up for me.
The thing was I loved
putting my heart into work.
I think we all did, right?
I loved hearing my friends
tell me about their research
and I loved the moment
I understood what they
were saying.
I got the science.
Yay, science.
But it meant something
special to me
and it didn't mean
anything special to me.
I had spent time
and energy and heart
on a field I thought I could
settle into and settle for,
but when it came down to it, I
realized it was stupid to settle
when other people weren't.
I realized the things that have
brought me the most satisfaction
during my time here were
outside the classroom
of my primary major, and
I don't think I'm online.
It's not that my heart
wasn't in the work.
It was just in other work.
It was in other classes in
another academic department
that wasn't on the path
I imagined for myself
but that made me feel like
I was doing something new,
something meaningful, but
two majors weren't enough.
Is enough ever enough
for CMU kids?
[laughs] I threw myself
into planning recruitment
with my sorority, Alpha Chi
Omega, and I spent hours
with the feminist club,
watching with glee
as I saw an entire lecture hall
filled with students taking time
to hear about women's bodies.
It was more than
just other work.
I found love in late-night
meetings with executive boards,
performing weird skits with
the chemistry department,
and building a booth.
Extracurriculars became
another academic program,
another degree, another
world outside problem sets --
a world of group meet texts,
Doodle polls, and
Google Calendar.
Who among us doesn't
know this world?
Whether we were RAs, TAs,
research team members,
team captains, or
chapter presidents,
no one is leaving this campus
without having been a part
of something outside the
work we set out to do.
Why did these activities
seem to matter just as much,
if not more, than
another assignment to turn
in by the midnight deadline?
Somewhere along the line,
the people around us
became friends we connected
with on a different level
than just getting things done.
You've probably heard that
we're among the smartest,
best educated, most
privileged people in the world.
Well, duh.
Despite the trials
and difficulties each
of us have faced both inside
and outside of this tiny,
tiny campus, we are all
incredibly lucky to be,
above all else, super smart.
Come on, pat yourself
on the back, smartasses.
You know what that
means, don't you?
We can't waste our brains.
We have an obligation to
do things that matter.
Carnegie Mellon has not been
an amazing experience just
because of our classes.
As we head out to careers,
to graduate programs,
to our parents' couches,
we must realize
that sometimes what
made us happiest
at CMU wasn't the work itself.
It was the heart put
into things and the care.
It was the TAs who guided us
through concepts of mathematics
and the friends who
helped us solve problems
that would never end, the
advisors and professors
who guided us towards paths
with meaning and purpose,
and the times we became
mentors, leaders, and guides.
"My heart is in the
work" doesn't tell us
to mindlessly dedicate
our hearts
to working for the sake of work.
It's a promise to
bring heart into work,
to do the things
we do with heart,
with passion, and with care.
Now, I'm not saying each of
us should dedicate our lives
to solving the world's biggest
problems, although, like,
at least one of us should deal
with the sustainable
energy crisis.
Chemical engineers, maybe
material science, one of you.
[laughs] Can one of
you take care of that?
[laughs] Thank you.
But honestly, most of us are
going to spend the next five,
maybe ten years doing stuff
that isn't our dream
job, and that's okay.
It's normal.
The things I found myself
able to put the most passion
into during my time here
were outside the classroom.
Maybe work will be
like that too.
Maybe some of us will struggle
to find meaning in the nine
to five, in tax forms
and hour-long commutes,
but what I ask of all of us
and what I hope for myself is
that we put our hearts
into a work.
We know how to work hard.
We've spent how many
years practicing it?
Our more challenging work will
be to work with our hearts,
to bring not only skill, talent,
and intelligence, but kindness,
thought, and love into
what we do every day --
into our workplaces,
communities, and families --
to treat the people outside
the Carnegie Mellon bubble
with the same respect
and wide-eyed wonder
as we treated each
other, to view the world
as optimistically
as we did here.
While Andrew Carnegie
is, was businessman,
he's not remembered
for his businesses.
He's remembered for
his philanthropy.
Carnegie Hall, Carnegie
museums, the Carnegie libraries,
Carnegie Mellon University --
Andrew Carnegie spent his
entire life putting his heart
into work, but his great sorrow
was to wait until the end
of his career to put heart into
the arts, education, service,
the good of the common man,
the things he cared about.
Why shouldn't we, in the
spirit of innovation,
improve upon his legacy?
As we leave, class of 2016,
let's make "my heart is
in the work" a promise to
bring our hearts into our work.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]